hop on zoom Mademoiselle in the
gentleman was gentleman in files you
have a winery in France do you not
the shine family winery
Nestle darling that's France big big
French bar we go in the kitchen and we
go whisk whisk whisk whisk whisk
pastries all over sweet Evelyn into your
mouth oh so good but we're not going to
be back we're not gonna be bacon today
we're gonna be drawn from memory we are
not artists speakers I am NOT an artist
former sketch boy actually my parents
were out this you see my blood do I
carry the same trite probably not based
on taste so we've got an assembly of
childhood heroes of ours those that
raised us and kept us warm in the
darkest of days I would only be able to
do this by looking in my neighbor's
window because we couldn't afford a TV
or a house I'm my neighbor I mean I
lived in the dirt alley outside
I had to peep in they had a big fence
and I climbed odor but one time I caught
a glimpse of Rocko's Modern Life and
that that's shaped Who I am to this day
I honestly every time you tell these
stories about how poor you are picture
you like hiding and sneaking around in
like a cow pen or a pig pen just I just
wanna see so I'm joined by wingus in
Vegas and we are going to recreate these
memories and then we're gonna be judged
by Amy of who did the best job okay how
much time do we have 90 seconds per
drawing are we ready
I'm ready are you yeah tell me yeah
how's my hair wasn't very convincing
okay the times gonna start as soon as I
say what it is okay ready Arnold from
Hey Arnold
Oh Karen I mean I didn't start off right
out here but just very difficult oh god
no it long legs long Oh legs time all
right let's go down the line
Arnold he's got the football head he's
got I remember his hair being slicked
back for some reason but that also
reminds me of something but I think that
was the girl that liked him that had the
bow oh he did her hat [ __ ] and then he
had his arms there he had long legs and
they called him Arnold they went anyway
so that horrible baby there all right
come here Jason
on my brain how it works it only
remembers the most important features
about everyone that I meet football hat
blonde hair had a two-layer sweater I
remember that very distinctly I don't
remember the color specifically but I
remember he always wore like to layer
like he had a button-up shirt I think it
was a red shirt over a green sweater but
I'm not a harp scent sure about that I
think he wore blue jeans but I didn't
have enough time so that's what I think
he looked like all right Arnold was
hugely depicted by his yellow skin tone
and the football shaped head he had like
a dirty blonde hair it was still blond
but it also had some brown in it he
definitely wore blue jeans on the time
and I remember him from the sequence of
don't hit me I'm crazy
I'll hit me we need place the boom box
and dances and like punches himself in
the face
did we get to see what he looks like
I was right hey oh yeah
he had a kilt that's right oh yeah the
fight against blue jeans on doesn't mean
he'll it was it was a it was a it was
his shirt coming below this was it I
always yeah I always thought it was a
killer
I'm shockingly close picking winners for
each one or no yeah yeah yeah wait who
won even it looks like the Rugrats kid
yeah you can saloon Ethan's a loser
creature yeah you were thinking Rugrats
kids next door
I would guess marks first just because
he has the callers the man is the only
one that I would guess I'll go first
you ready sandy from Sponge Bob
[Music]
[Laughter]
the main thing that I remembered was the
suit I remember it being this very
blocky cylindrical thing the boots you
know the gloves were like mittens the
only thing I remember about the face was
squirrels are kind of brown in color I
think she had a bow but I might be wrong
I might be wrong about that but other
than that spot-on I just remember saying
he being the underwater scrolling in
like an astronaut suit she also lived in
a bubble but I couldn't get to that part
where she lived in the bubble and had
the water seal door and like they said
this is the one when they went above
water and it's the realistic ocean
cheeks the thing that nobody else has is
her big chalmers big big Chompy teeth
that is what she was known for she had a
bubble around her head her suit the the
tail I believe came out of her suit
which was something that you know really
you really got to think about it because
like in water leaked in because she
couldn't be underwater obviously because
I don't think she had a tail she did
have a tail she's a she has okay she has
a tail what I'm saying is that her tail
I don't think it came out of the suit
suit because I watched that show a lot I
don't think I was to show a lot - I
thought you're a poor are you lonely
that doesn't mean that everyone else is
right I'm right you're wrong what you
were almost right though she didn't have
a bow she had like a flower I appreciate
that you use the whole campus I think I
like Tyler's the most I think
I get a big Sandia field from Ethan if
you finished a little bit more so I
guess the suit is good it's very clearly
his hair all-right tile there you go
Johnny Bravo distinctly had a black
shirt blue jean pants his shades and
that wicked awesome front blond hair
spiked and he'd just be like oh yeah
big ass arms big-ass teeth big
sunglasses big hair big legs everything
about Johnny Bravo don't go back there
blue jeans black shirt didn't have time
to color it in shoes you've got a belt
buckle and big muscles big smile all
right okay so the first feature I drew
was the hair cuz that everyone knows the
hair right but what a lot a lot of
people know you know you get the basics
like the hair the shades the small mouth
it kind of small mountain but the
triangular curvature of his tour zone it
not only was triangles but or is a
curved in yeah his torso it curved in
cuz he was always forward you know he
was always jutting forward with that oh
you know
it also legs much smaller than like
proportionally big arms
whoa mama oh mama I was give them a bit
more you know well but I got the swoop
in see I think the whoa mama is really
cells I was the only one that saw the
nose you also got the same teeth as
sandy who wins yes hey Kim Possible oh I
didn't watch this doo doo as too poor
time would you like to see baby the
classic song ringtone that you hear
before your big mission whose mission
Kim Possible's mission a few things
about it she replies what's the sitch
first thing about her she's got some big
swoopy hair second thing she had a
long-sleeve shirt that was also a little
bit of a crop top a little bit and then
the classic real baggy cargo pants that
were green this is me
I'm done here far too poor to ever watch
this show so I never saw it the only
thing I think I remember was that she
remembers she had brown hair I guess she
had I'm Kim that's impossible so other
people gonna go like possible Kim goes
on a mission she wears all black she
also has red head she's a redhead not
brown haired and she has green eyes and
she puts her hair back in a ponytail
when she's on a mission hey I got it
pretty I know did the mustache Ethan
kind of looks like a Lego
well I feel like that's unfair but
whatever did you see mine I forgot the
nose the first thing that jumped to mind
was big bulging eyes leave a hole in his
tooth he has a balloon
oh I kind of forgot what a dog looked
like halfway through I tried to get the
floppy ear and then I forgot this
probably goes out to a snout or
something yeah but purple a purple fur
hole in tooth big eyes little
three-pronged hands and yeah he's been
neutered I think the biggest thing about
snout in his head is bigger than the
rest of his body he's got tiny little
feet and tiny little arms this is from
the plant attack episode where plant
tries the courage and his eyes are red
because he's freaked out and scared yes
here we have his big ears he had big
ears he had big eyes he always has not
his eyebrows we're always like oh his
tongue sticking out it also kind of
looks like he's coughing up blood yeah
like a little cylindrical body little
tiny arms and then I started to draw
Eustace it's totally different depending
on the pose Ethan's got the ears how
those colors are pretty unpause though I
guess the tooth tower had like the tiny
limbs the tiny limbs look I'd say
Ethan's is the most
[Music]
that's commitment to the earth I
remember a girl from invader zim is
always being like hungry and so I
remember him like drooling
I've watched maybe three episodes of
invader zim and I just know he's like
drawing and I guess like a purple suit
that he wears sometimes and he's green
okay I don't think he's I don't think
he's green I think he has green eyes but
he's a little robot so I think he's like
silverish her gray and I think he goes
Oh a lot which is why the mouth is in Oh
for I couldn't recall if he had like an
antenna or anything but I drew him there
cuz guessing I think if he goes into
battle mode his eyes go red or something
like that yeah yeah something like that
either way that's it's pretty pretty
pretty accurate I'd say I couldn't
remember if he had blue skin or purple
skin so I put him off there you know
Brian Gore beegley he got his first part
of his name from this so I put Brian's
intro thing which is koror beagley and
then his catchphrases once play
everything so it depends on if he's
wearing his little dog suit or not oh
but I got the robot for him surprisingly
really yeah Wow the other two look more
like cinder oh yes yes now that you were
thinking I was not there
for me double d double D having freckles
he's got like a very like wide head and
then he had some sort of hat on I
couldn't remember and then he was always
like unsure about everything he was
always on that and didn't really want to
be doing stuff then he was always
yelling at already red shirt beanie
never took it off
loves jawbreakers just as much as the
rest of them drooling at the site no
muscle mass whatsoever
lucious bill yes red shirt blue pants
that were really baggy he had buck teeth
and was nerdy Andy wore beanie and it
was real scrawny guy and he was not
yelling at the other two he was the more
shy one than the other ones orange oh
let me get closer cuz it's a little
small because it takes a long time to
cover a lot of space do not see your
bird feet of a giant Bravo he was fine
better than that took up the whole pet
you know fine fine whatever you're gonna
get two minutes for this one Dexter and
Dee Dee Dexter's Lab
[Music]
so the only thing I remember about
Dexter I love this show when I could
watch at the library but I know that
Bob's minecraft avatar is based on
Dexter so I just tried to draw Bob at
the right height and I know there was
orange hair and I remember these pointed
boots and that was about as all I
remember
DeeDee ballerina so the pointed toe I
believe this is fourth position hands
above the head couldn't remember the
hair that hair is correct my hair is not
correct I will admit that but everything
else flawless about my approach PD is
supposed to be taller so ignored the
fact that this is there but Dexter in
this sequence is yelling that deedie
because deedie is always messing with
his stuff and Deedee's like a ballerina
and dancing around blonde hair
distinctly has the bows I can't remember
if she's always pink but I remember
wearing blue and at least one episode
and Dexter's Panzers I remember a purple
so he always has blood codon he always
has the orange curly hair is glasses and
lab coat and the the purple pants
Dexter is very very small he's got that
orange hair he's very mad because Dee
Dee's messing with this stuff dee dee
towers above Dexter always and forever
she's always running around with her
arms up doing ballerina things he's very
short and stub and Quentin Chhotu
he's got his lab coat on which you can
see very clearly here because of the
collar I got the tutu oh yeah the hair
was straight out that's that's how his
hair also he's singing
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I think I like yours the Mugen line even
has the best look of disappointment all
right you guys ready for this it's a
fight and it's between link from Zelda
versus odd job my job want to be in the
scene fighting he throws that and me way
off to the side so the link would be
saying there with his master sword
having to defend against objects hat Wow
[Music]
no I'm a youtuber no surgery big boy do
I have a job a job is not odd job
himself but the Austin Powers version of
odd job job I don't know but you know I
know that the Austin Powers version was
making fun of odd job and he was like a
big kind of Asian guy with a bowler hat
and he would but he threw a shoe in
there but I don't know
and when he's floating there's link he's
got the Hat green elf ears thumb talk
big Master Sword why is the sword Feeny
cuz the Master Sword and the tunic was
like a kilt I will say our job was very
small so you were definitely thinking
the Austin Powers version um they're all
good guys I just I have to give a Tyler
I think I don't think you should get
credit for not drawing them but whatever
I whatever I do like the angry turnip
look good yeah helpful - oh I can't tell
who that is that's like yeah
also the master swords a blue but I
didn't have time odd-job has a body
where's our Joseph over there oh you
can't say that you lazy piece of crap
wait don't do the hand motion yeah mark
winds are known overall hide and gave
tyler so many other ones you all win
this dummy so thank you everybody so
much for watching thank you to wingus
and dingus thank you guys who were
screaming at the screen saying i
remember them better oh yeah oh yeah
oh did you oh are you zooming
oh there we go anyway check out Ethan at
crank game place link in the description
he's on Twitch Apocalypto underscore 12
link in the description thanks everyone
for watching if you got other things you
wants to do let us know in the comments
thanks again as always we'll see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]